It might be easy to forget that "Xena: Warrior
Princess" was a spinoff. Originally appearing
as a secondary character in "Hercules: The
Legendary Journeys," Xena launched her own
show and blew past "Hercules" in popularity,
eventually becoming a wild ratings success.
"Starring Kevin Sorbo. Michael Hurst.
And, for the first time ever, Lucy
Lawless as Xena, Warrior Princess!
In fact, "Xena : Warrior Princess" was so popular,
the spinoff series actually almost spawned
it's own spinoff series called "Amazon High".
Sadly, though, it never aired. Why?
The clues can be found in season
5 of "Xena: Warrior Princess,"
which featured one very unusual episode. And
that's saying something, considering that "Xena"
Season 5 mostly focused on an evil baby and
Xena's slaughter of all the Olympian gods. But
"Lifeblood," Episode 16, stands out because
it includes a time-traveling Selma Blair.
"Lifeblood" recycled footage from the two-hour
unaired pilot of "Amazon High," starring Blair,
which would have been a spinoff from "Xena."
Blair played Cyane, a modern girl of 1998,
who by way of a magic dagger is
transported into caveman times,
centuries before even the
story of "Xena" takes place.
In "Amazon High," Cyane is considered the
chosen one in a tribe of female warriors.
Cyane butts heads with Samsara, played by "Xena"
regular Danielle Cormack, and becomes friends with
a girl who can communicate with animals. She's
then captured by a tribe of cannibals led by Kor,
played by another "Xena" regular, future film
star Karl Urban. Cyane later befriends Kor,
domesticates horses, and names her
new tribe of warrior women "Amazons."
So why didn't "Amazon High" work out?
The show's main writer, Rob Tapert,
had a pretty impressive hit rate. Tapert created
"Xena," then moved on to other syndicated shows
like "Cleopatra 2525" and "Young Hercules."
"Amazon High" seemed like a sure thing, right?
Well, it should have been. Syndicated shows
were big business in the early '90s. "Baywatch"
proved that such shows could be financially
profitable. And according to the LA Times,
"Xena" and its predecessor "Hercules" actually
outperformed "Baywatch" at one point. It would
make sense to try and get another show
out of the swords and sandals franchise.
The problem for Tapert was that the
success of "Xena" and "Hercules"
spawned a lot of imitators. Tapert told the
website "Book of the Dead" that he decided to
axe "Amazon High" at the very moment they
signed a deal to make the show, saying,
"Everybody was pleased with what they bought.
And I was standing at a monitor [...] watching
'The Lost World' promo, and I said, 'You
know what, we've been ripped off so many
times [...] we have to do something fresh.'"
Around this time, there were similar shows
on the air about Tarzan, Sinbad, and Conan
the Barbarian. Tapert told the "LA Times",
"The 'Baywatch' people are doing Sinbad, and
of course there are a bunch of other rip-offs
on the way. I mean, what are we going
to do: 'Young Moses, Freedom Fighter'?"
So Tapert took the basic "'90s woman time
travels back to a more savage time" plot
and flipped it, creating "Cleopatra
2525" - a show about a modern exotic
dancer traveling forward in time and
fighting the robots that have taken
over the earth. It was an early breakout
role for "Firefly" star Gina Torres.
While we'll never know how things would
have turned out for "Amazon High,"
Tapert may have had the right idea about needless
imitators flooding the market with copycat shows.
But at least we got "Xena!"
"From this moment on, we are the amazons!"
"Amazons rule!!!"
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.